Allah says in surah bakar chapter 2
verse number 143 that we have made you
an um a midl community so that you may
be a witness over the nations and the
messenger will be a witness over
you it's our duty to convey the message
of Allah subhana wa
t'ala and our life the Islamic life is a
balanced life unlike other
beliefs it either talks about the body
of fulfillment of the soul.
Islam the solution is for the body and
for the
soul. A beloved prophet said it's
mentioned in Sai Bkari volume number
three had number
1975 the beloved prophet said Abdullah
one of the Sabbath may Allah be with him
I have heard that you fast all days and
pray full nights he said yeah Allah the
prophet said do not do it fast one day
do not fast the next day pray part of
the night sleep for part of the night
your body has a right over you. Your
wife has a right over you. So Islam is a
justly balanced
religion. It doesn't believe in
monasticism. Doesn't believe in
renouncing the world. The dunya in Islam
is part of the
dean. It is a holistic solution.
And furthermore, when we see when people
talk about happiness, talking about
billionaires, we know the example of
Christina
on who inherited wealth after her father
died who was a billionaire and during
interview she was asked that you are the
richest woman in the world. She said yes
I'm the richest woman in the world but
also the most unhappiest woman in the
world.
She didn't get peace. She didn't get
happiness. And later on she committed
suicide. And this is common family
problems and all
more in the rich than the poor. It's
there in both. But rich wealth does not
get you
happiness. Allah says the wealth is a
fit the test for you.
And Allah says in the
Quran in Surah chapter number 13 verse
number 28, verily in the remembrance of
Allah do hearts find
contentment. Verily in the remembrance
of Allah do hearts find
contentment. And that reminds me of a
very good example of one of the greatest
scholars of the medieval age.
And we knew he lived a life of
poverty. He was imprisoned. He was
threatened by his enemy. He was
tortured. So when the enemy threatened
him, what did
she
said? He said that what can you do to
me? What can you do to me? If you
imprison me, if you put me in jail, I
would do zikar of
Allah. Zikar praise.
and remember
Allah. If you exile me, I
would I would contemplate on the
creation of Allah. If you execute me, I
would be a shahid. I would be a martyr.
My ja is in my
heart. Imagine a person who's not afraid
of dying. Whatever you want to do, you
do. You cannot take away the ja.
My ja is in my heart and I'm not of this
dy I'm for a so this is true
happiness even though he lived in
poverty even though he was taught and if
you read the statement
of may Allah have mercy on him he was
one of the well-known students of Islam
he
says the life that alsia lived of
poverty he was imprisoned but I've never
seen in my life Any man who's more
happier
than imagine life of poverty being
tortured to give up his mission he
didn't
budge if you imprison me I will desikar
of Allah if you exile
me I will contemplate on the creation of
Allah if you execute me I'll be shahid
my ja is in my heart so he cannot take
away his
ja so this is True
happiness. True
happiness. And that reminds
me that once a Jew goes to Hajarcalani
who was a judge, he was
rich and a Jew, a poor man comes and
tells him that your prophet said that
this dunya is like a jail imprisonment
for the believers and for unbelievers
it's paradise. I am poor. My clothes are
tattered. You're rich. You're living a
luxurious life. How can you explain this
hadith
said those believers who know what is
waiting for them in a ja even if you're
the richest man in this world all the
happiness compared to Jenna is like
compared to Jenna is like imprisonment.
And if the unbelievers
knew what is there for them in the hakra
hell and the lowest the coolest fire in
hell if it touches your feet your brains
will boil. If they know where they will
go even if they are the worst human
being in this world for them this is
ja. This is explanation of hadith of
beloved prophet wasallam. So
Jenna happiness is a
state your belief your